hello I think we where we can start I'm
glad to be here
it's my first time in London on this
side of the river
my name is Adina I'm from Romania in the
second-largest city called the ash I'm a
Software Architect at Indaba maybe you
heard of this company it's based in
London and I organized the meetup where
I try to bring people together to learn
things and try to encourage them to
teach things to other people and also I
teach dotnet on Saturdays for 5 hours
but about me that's enough what we're
going to talk about today is very easy
and simple just because we treat it
lightly we all talk about rest we brag
about you ourselves that we implement
the rest api's when actually we kind of
don't so that's why I chose the topic to
talk up a little bit about West and
about graph QL because it's a bit of a
hype right now at least in the front-end
world so we're going to talk about rest
constraints well I do not agree with
rest constraints because if they were a
constraint everybody would respect them
there are more like a guideline that US
developers need to respect to have a
fully capable and liveable API so these
constraints or guidelines are just a few
but the most easy one is client server I
heard about this architecture in school
as being the most simple architecture
and actually it was the first time I
heard about architecture in other domain
than like construction so client-server
what does this mean well it means that
we have two parties involved a client
and a server that both needs to be
pretty much up at the same time and they
need to understand each
the client asks something for the server
and the server needs to understand what
it's asked for and to respond back
another constraint or guideline is that
it should be stateless as an
architectural style represents a
representational state transfer this is
rest invented by Roy fielding in about
2000 I think in his dissertation thesis
we take this arrest as a concept very
lightly and we read it superficially so
stateless what it means that is
stateless or it should be stateless
basically the server should have
absolutely no trace about the previous
requests that have been made so
stateless if you heard this word it's
about HTTP mostly right HTTP protocol
doesn't retain any state and the rest
comes over this HTTP and says you know
what if you issue a request everything
that you want in that request should be
self-contained so that the server should
understand that request in isolation so
you should have absolutely no trace of
all of what it has been before right
even is this then I don't know well log
in detailed a token of any kind that
token should be contained in the request
itself not stored in a cookie not I
don't know hidden in somewhere hidden
feels like like we used to do in a ESP
other versions we had web forms have you
worked with web forms yeah nice we had a
lot of hidden fields they're just
maintained States
caching this guideline says that we
should use caching as a specification
very intensively like cache stuff in the
browser's in the clients browser use it
from there and so on uniform in an
interface it's pretty much a bigger
constraint that says that everything is
a resource and no matter what it is in
our application it should be treated as
a resource and
that's it moreover what we exposed to
the public to our api's it's a
representation of what we have we do not
expose domain models directly to
whatever client we have we expose a
representation of those resources we
work with and also this uniform
interface says that we should have self
descriptive messages that is strictly
tied in to that previous constraint
stateless if you if you request
everything should be there every header
that you ever need every I don't know
body that you need the URL that you need
should be in that request itself and it
should be like self explanatory when you
look at the request hate OS who ever
heard of it
who ever implemented my point exactly
so it basically says that it's
hypermedia as the Angel of application
state the server should be the one that
drives everything and in each request
should have a part that tells the client
you know what from here you can navigate
through there or backwards or to the
other links but we often refuse to do
that because we think that is a
performance penalty and we simply do not
use that and it's a major part in the
rest api s-- so i never did it in my
api's so you didn't so we completely
ignore this part so if you talk about
rest a rest api should be about verbs
right words the fourth ones main ones
that we're using get post put delete and
it's real meaning we have more verbs we
don't do not use those but we often use
even post verbs to update resources you
did that I did it
I admit I deserved a moment in my
developers life when I was a juror I did
that because I don't know it was like a
folklore
everyone did that and so I did so for
example headers you use headers
extensively to specify what you need
from an API depends on the context you
ever implemented custom headers to read
from in a request and then on the server
side to distinguish what you need to
return back you did that
sorry so how about status codes we know
the mainstream ones 404 we use it in
jokes and so on but how many of you use
state correct status codes good for you
for example after a post request write a
post request should have as a result
creation of the new racers somewhere and
it's not enough a 10.8 the important
real issue right so if you issue the
same request over and over again if you
have a business logic that is strong you
shouldn't be allowed to
I know create duplicate resources right
so what status code do you return as a
result of a post request 201 201 is a
success that status codes that says you
know what this was created right so we
tend not to use that I don't know why
but I admit I used to do that but also
if you I don't know issue requests to
create something the request the request
is good but you have something in your
business logic that says you know what
this is a duplicate thing you cannot
create this thing you're trying to
because you already have one let's think
about the case like I don't know
register ring with an email right the
email address theoretically should be
unique so if you try to register more
than once with
email you should get back status code
what is that status code 400 but my
request is okay not modified or how
about 409 which means conflict I mean
this is the way we are adding meaning to
our requests hence the responses and the
responses using one of the 41 were
status codes that are available for us
this way when we see I don't know if a
tester gives back a bug you can look at
the requests and you can see at first
hand what's happening I mean you can
tell that tester you know what 409 means
something you didn't request okay but
our business logic says that you cannot
effectuate this operation how fight
about media types we don't play around
with accept property headers or content
type to get a different representation
of the resources I don't know why we
don't do that maybe because it's hard
sometimes in a.net to implement that but
what if we would have like intuitive
endpoints if you're talking about res
we're also talking about naming right
there are tons of blog posts and
guidelines that says okay your endpoint
should have a plural name to indicate
that the endpoint deals with multiple
resources right and we add meaning to
each and every single verb status called
hypermedia that we are using and Heather
and we often forget that so forgetting
that we're basically forgetting about
HTTP our we are not adding I don't know
Heather's to specify that a certain
resource is catchable and for how long
and in which cases we're not using
attacks to help on that we also and more
often than not we rely on other
technologies to do that instead of us
and because REST API is responds to
different needs we could also have
through Heather's something that is
called content negotiation and it's very
nicely implemented in asp.net core if
you know how to turn off and turn on
certain features for example to a
specific header due to content
negotiation that happens on the server
side you might get a 200 as a response
code and adjacent body back as a
response and with a different header you
might get back a 200 with an XML
representation of that raster's and also
adding a different header maybe you get
no content in a body and a 415 as a
status code and that should indicate you
what it's happening in there 415 in the
indicates that well your server doesn't
know how to answer to you with that
format you are asking so each party
needs to communicate through these
mechanisms okay what are the rest api
benefits for example for want to to tell
you a short story when i switch
companies i blended on a specific
project that was very big and the
developers were bragging that state of
the art microservices rest api and when
i looked at the earth specification
Swagger's and so on i saw that they had
in endpoints slash new whatever
wrestlers slash create that is not a
rest guideline and so further along that
they didn't have micro services in real
meaning but let's stick to the basics so
rest api should be scalable right
because it is discoverable and it's
intuitive we you I don't know you have
an API that I don't know
sells cats food right it should be very
easy for you to look at the end point
and to figure it out what are the next
requests you can do on that those
resources for example how many of you
after a post requests include in the
headers the location of the new resource
that was created good one
find me later to talk about it also a
REST API that by the book should be
evolvable because it's all about
interest evolvability moreover the
server should drive the application
state because you'll see further along
that also drive the application state
but also the client and the server can
evolve independently is something like
this we have the horse but maybe the
course evolves in an unicorn or your
carriage becomes something with more it
doesn't mean that these entities cannot
live together it can live together but
using the the specifics of rest v1 it's
familiar it is how many of you had v1
until the end of the life of that
application from the beginning of that
application I did
so versioning again we forget about
headers so we forget about everything in
there and we stick with v1 from the
beginning till the end and after we
switched jobs and after the but I don't
know the business dies we have beyond
but the entities in that V on changed
dramatically over time
so our STP eyes are aware our traitors
superficially and this is one of the
reason I chose the topic because you
need discipline and pressured by the
delivery time we often do not have time
to to have discipline and needs constant
design so some I say that ok
we have issues when dealing with REST
API s but those issues can be solved
through constant design but we do not
have time to do that so I'm gonna give
you a quote here says that a reason to
make a real REST API is to get
evolvability a v1 is the middle finger
to your API customers indicating that in
fact is not the rest
it's a HTTP RPC style who said that the
inventor of rest in 2300 twit and it's
very nice because it's so real so if you
have v1 pretty much you'll stick with v1
so versioning in REST API should be done
to headers mostly because they said that
cool you are eyes don't change stay the
same so if you are the v1 and then a v2
you kind of change the URL the you are
eyes also a big issue with rest is that
those api's are chatty tend to bring
everything over to the client side
forces you to get something else
if you additional requests and have
something like this right every time
when you have an API exposed to a client
in your team or not your team you have
exact fetching right the client gets
exactly what they need right no it's not
think about it you own the API and maybe
you have some colleagues that are
working on the client side and then you
can talk with them they will tell you
what they need you will tell them what
you send from the API you discuss you
remove properties that are returning
reasons and pretty much this is it it's
a constant chitchat right between the
teams to decide what it's needed but if
the rest doesn't do exact thing we force
exact fetching by discussing with other
teams what would happen
if for example you would have an API
exposed to the public and you do not own
the client you would have absolutely no
way to know what is used from your API
or whatnot so basically rest it's about
over fetching and under fetching what
means over fetching means that you kind
of get more data that you need for your
point and some people in the industry
said yeah okay that is done and
solved by constant design but we do not
do that so we'll stick we stick to this
problem
if you're lucky enough to have time we
are not under fetching forces you to
make other calls to get additional data
to fill out the page think about it if
you have an online store right you have
a list of products and then you click on
a product and you have I don't know
description images and so on and then
you have a table with reviews and then
the table with I don't know price
fluctuations and so on every single of
those it's an additional request to get
data to populate the single page so it
forces you to bring to make more calls
and transfer data over the network more
than you need so a rest client was first
used to do this call an endpoint for a
restaurant for example to get a list of
restaurants then you pick one and then
you will get an endpoint for that
restaurant ID and then you are
interested in reviews like we all use
TripAdvisor when you go some places to
see what's around and how good it is so
it will force us to do all these
requests and if they're only these
requests we're lucky but additional
things in more complicated application
we require more more calls for data
transfer and more money from our
business because all this data is made
is transferred to the network so REST
API is almost fully use HTTP
we have no hypermedia to drive the
application state because we think that
is performance ban on penalty and we do
not want that we kind of forget about
the usage of feathers is resource based
but naming is complicated
even in variables more than endpoints
depending on how complicated the
business is so we kind of bad name stuff
in West we kinda have no way of I don't
know modeling actions have you ever
encountered a situation like this you
have like I don't know an action to
model do that well it's kinda not a
wrestlers so it doesn't meet the
requirements to plural the IDE and the
relational stuff it's an action I
compute something do the math it's not
in the guidelines how do you pass the
parameters to add those it's complicated
so we stick to bad names except versus
content types very important properties
in heathers that we often forget that
will give us back resources that are
different or different representation in
fact of the same arrestors sub
descriptive messages status codes as
they should be most of us did all these
things or didn't do so why not choose
different technologies that will
completely remove everything that we
need to know about rest and simplify our
lives so then we're gonna see about
graph QL what it is so it is a query
language invented by Facebook because we
all stay on Facebook squirrel around get
a ton of information at once very fast
they kept it internally until around
2015 and then expose it to the public
and nowadays it's a
popular technology in the front-end
world they have a polo client that does
a lot of things and so on
but today we're gonna see how it is to
implement such an API for a client
whatever the client is in dotnet so a
credit language that promises to solve
the issue with over fetching and
over/under fetching that rest has
Facebook used it github has v4 API that
is fully on on graph QL Yelp Kyle lamb
PayPal pretty much big players in
industry use graph killed or exposed end
points based on graph QL so will get
only this using graph QL okay so if we
switch back and revise the schema with
the request now we have a client that
issues a request and gets back data from
three other places but doing just one
request pretty nice right I mean three
calls to an API that aren't made and we
get the data that we need without
calling I don't know the reviews the ID
and so on all that was pretty neat so
something like this API speakers
collection endpoint by ID is something
related to won't be there you won't need
it forget about it
so now in graph GL we do not have all
the meaning that we should have had in
arrest
we have only posed as a verb which will
not do gets or put or deletes
we do only post we can add headers and
we do not care about status codes at all
so think about this we have an endpoint
that returns speakers we are at the
conference and we know about speakers so
maybe we have this kind of information
that comes back but we need only the
pink
arrests api's would be pretty hard to
implement how about the end point by ID
that is a convention also we need only
the pink ones so what do we do in rest
we go to the database and remove them
completely no we need them maybe on the
administration side outside of the
website we need them we need to store it
so how do we do this and rest well in
rest
you either create the different
endpoints or use the headers the correct
headers to get you only the pink ones or
pretty much this is it but it's pretty
it's tedious to do that right to create
a different representation of the same
resource when you need only those pink
fields
how about related stuff you need for
these Pickers all the at the talks maybe
you're interested in a history for a
certain conference how about if you
would get something like this at once so
you get a description the title the
speaker and the first name at once you
do join a database right but the
endpoint ingress would be the same okay
let's forget about her as for now and
move on
what is graph QL and what are the
building blocks basically because it's a
query language we have a schema where we
need to define a framework where we need
to define the things that we are working
on and exposing we will have queries
that will represent basically to get get
requests we're used to in arrests we
will have mutation that is that post
request that I told you that is made to
do like add stuff update or delete data
so basically have three verbs in one and
it's called a mutation and then we have
subscription like where you can
subscribe to event and expose those it's
based on fields resolvers and types that
are predefined in
Raphael and you can extend those to make
your own so what is a query in graph QL
basically a query is everything that can
be questioned from the outside it can
have headers you maybe need to have
additional logic in there that you put
in headers you're allowed to do that and
you can run several in parallel for
example you can run a query at the same
time to get your feedbacks and to get
talks ok what do you need to do is to
use a tool right something like this
that is very similar to Jason it's not
Jason but it's ish Jason ish so you
start with the query type and then
you'll have like I'm interested in the
query that I exposed to cold speakers
and from those speakers I need only
those properties what you'll get back
you'll get something like this that is
pretty much real Jason that has only the
properties you need the same you can do
for a query by an ID nothing stops you
to include an ID there so for example
I'm interested in the talk talk with ID
2 and I'm interested in the description
the title and the speakers and from the
speaker's only the last name and I will
get back data like this all at once ok
let's see a bit of how it works I'm
gonna run this and then we're gonna dig
into dotnet details you can also use
postman to make queries and I'm gonna
show you this
I hope it's visible enough okay for
example I told you that that we start
with query as a keyword and from there
we're gonna have all the options that we
expose like intelligence in visual
studio so from here I'm gonna be
interested in speakers and from these
speakers I'm interested in the company
name and also in the first name this is
exactly what I want to I want to to get
back I'm gonna click prettify to make
that them aligned I'm gonna run it and
I'm gonna get pretty much all the
speakers that I have in my database a
big database but pretty much this is it
it's simple as that what it happened
what it happens behind the scenes is
that a post request is issued to my
endpoint and I get back the data in JSON
format because it's the only format that
it knows how to to use right now okay a
mutation well a mutation it's either
post are there an update
I never delete it also can have headers
but you only you can only run it one by
one so you cannot like create two
entities at once just one by one so a
mutation looks like this it won't have
the query a keyword anymore it will have
a mutation keyword and then you need to
define variables like in JavaScript
for example this mutation is called
create talk and it has a parameter
called talk and we define it with a
dollar because it's a it's a JavaScript
ish parameter so I create the talk and
when I get the answer back
I need the title description and the
speaker ID for the talk
so I create with this parameter and I
get back only the three fields that I
specified okay this is mutation seems
simple and to me it seems very
GRP see old stylish calls or soap have
you ever used soaped that had with those
tough where all the action words were
available a pretty much it's similar
because now you do not have the
intuitive endpoints to to allow you to
issue different kinds of a requests
another thing that is available in graph
QL is a subscription where you can use
signaler and different the other
technologies but Internet is done
through WebSockets
so if you want to expose a subscription
in the client you need to use signal art
but between services it's down to
WebSocket where basically you subscribe
to events right your interest rate to be
notified whenever something is created
or updated or a specific mutation
it's called okay so this is about all
the theoretical stuff around graph QL
and we're gonna see how it is to do with
this in dotnet because that's why you're
here okay right click new projects API
and so on right what you need to do to
install everything that you need for
graph PL you need you saw the package
called graph QL then another package
called transport ASP not for then you
need to install a playground a
playground is basically that graphical
interface that allows you to do queries
easily more intuitive has that
intelligence ish stuff and then you need
to add middle words sometimes and then
you need to create the schema the schema
was that building block that comprises
queries mutations and subscriptions and
then you'll need to resolve every way
that you want to expose true dependency
injection and then resolve mutations and
if you have resolved subscriptions so
you're done no you're not because
basically we're gonna see
that you will need to define your graph
entities everywhere will prevail in your
application to expose to the public
every mutation that it ever needed in
the application schema mutation to build
add feel by field how does this sound
right but unfortunately unfortunately
they did something like this so you have
the conference schema because this is
the topic of the application I'm having
as a deal so you need to have conference
kheema that is inherited from graph QL
schema and then you inject that
dependency resolver and you specify you
know what I have a query as a general
building block of my graph QL ap I have
a query resolve this through the
conference query and then if you have
mutations you have to do the same so
this schema will only have like three
blocks queries mutations and then
subscriptions if you have after you
define this then you need to deal with
the entities that you expose to this API
for example I'm exposing a speaker a
speaker as in a different time that type
that in my domain model and here one by
one I need to specify the fields that
I'm exposing true after I inherited of
object graph type of my real domain
object okay you need to do this and
after this you're pretty much done with
the entities that you were exposing
after you define the speaker entity then
you need to go in your query the main
building block that is the query just to
say you know what I have a query that is
called speakers so if you have speakers
in your playground you might see the
list of fields that you previously
defined in the endo type so how is that
resolved well easy you have
description just to help you out and
you'll have resolved and what you doing
that resolve is to call your repository
to get everything that you need in there
so this is all the resolving stuff a
mutation it's pretty much similar you
need to define help I feel the input
type so pretty much what you require for
a post for example what are the field
that you require for a post you give
that mutation a name and then you need
to resolve it basically you need to
specify there what happens when somebody
uses your mutation calling a repository
to save that day okay
pretty much this is it in big lines so
let's see it in code I hope is visible
enough okay so starting from scratch I
will show you the general structure
pretty much I have the data a data
classical you saw it everywhere as a
project structure
I have entities domain entities I have
speaker with a few properties I have a
talk with a few properties and from
there I have repositories with crud
operations so I have get all I have get
by ID and I have the add one pretty much
to cover every scenario for a specific
entity and from there I also have where
is it talks in a similar manner so I
have get all get all for a certain
speaker get all by ID and add so pretty
much everything it's common right okay
so this is the data part and then I will
have another that we are going to talk
about later a service where you can
aggregate data don't do that but it as a
home it works so graph QL API so let's
see a little bit in startup
you need to wire things up and by wiring
using dependency injection for your type
you already do this and also you need to
have the conference schema so the schema
will be the one that will pretty much
hold everything every one of the three
building blocks in graph QL a query
mutation and a subscription if you have
one and you need to say that okay I have
a query that is found in here and you
need to resolve that in the same manner
you'll have like a mutation and every
mutation that is available in my app is
found here so resolve them okay
then you will need to have the add graph
kill write log in play and then you say
to the platform use graph filled with
the conference schema that contain
contains every query and mutation and
subscription in my API and then you have
the option of configuring different UI
tools of six months back there was only
one that came as a default which was
this which is not I do not prefer this
when showing it to people because the
contrast is not good but I can also have
something like graphical not this that
it's cleaner I think and white and
easier to follow so pretty much in here
I will run everything that I exposed to
the application I'm gonna click to
execute and I get the results in the
right side it's very intuitive and very
nice for a developer as a experience so
I get this intelligence - stuff that
they also allows me to to select
whatever I need there so unity it's
added in the other side as
response okay so graph QL playground is
the default one and graphical is the
other one how do you obtain that what
depending on the color you prefer is
like ref geoserver
UI and then you have several options to
choose from there are like I know four
or five that are available for you to
use
meanwhile the open source contributors
guys worked and included those in a
in.net hey yeh to them okay so let's get
back to the our queries so our queries a
query that building block domain the get
ones from the rest are defined in here
so I say I have a query available under
this name speakers that has a
description and that will resolve by
calling my speaker repository at all
easy as that but this field comes from a
graph key on this graph type so it's a
list of graph type of type speaker
you'll see a lot of templating in graph
GL how a speaker defined looks like so
it's basically a different class some
some guys use like speaker inputs outs
or speaker query just to discern the
entities because what you basically do
is to inherit from your domain object
picker as you have it in the database
with all the fields you need there and
then build on it to define it under the
graph QL name so field ID blah blah blah
and the description so for example if
you remove a field from here you won't
see it anymore in the playground so it
won't be available to be queried in
there so pretty neat you need to do
another class that hurts from your test
you'll have it all in here so going back
speakers so I'm interested in a company
name description last name let's add
another one first name and run it you'll
see you'll see the stuff in here okay
this is with the speaker is the most
simple one let's see what else do we
have so we have in here something that
will be available under the queer name
talks so I will be able to get the talks
by using this a small description and
then how it will be resolved by getting
all talks acing right we'll talk about
the behind the scenes a little bit later
ok so I can get back to my graphical and
say you know what I'm not interested in
speaker area anymore
I'm interested in talks and from the
talks I need a description and let's run
it say depending on this playgrounds you
are using you will need to add here it
requires me the keyword query and
graphical it doesn't so you need to know
what you're doing there okay so talks
descriptions blah blah blah and I'm
interested and what we are exposing so
I'm interested maybe in the title okay
and I'm gonna run it so okay I also get
the title for each talk I get here and
I'm also may be interested in feedbacks
feedbacks is another query that is made
in another object
let me show in a sec if you run this
without any property specified you'll
get an error you you not get an error
feedbacks run it has a default ID
graphical pretty nice okay that's right
here talks description okay
feedbacks I think it's the first time
when I speaker once is demo2 to break
and it doesn't want to break anyhow
voila
yay so depending on the playground
you'll get something like this message
not the status code just a message with
a validation error it says that feedback
of type blah blah blah must have a sub
selection which means that it forces me
to go in here under feedbacks and select
what I need from that object so for
example I need to delivery and I also
need some content and then when I run it
I should get an array of feedbacks with
those properties I am specifying ok get
him back to the code looking at the
talks so I have here talks ok on the
same pattern that I used before in the
speakers I'm inheriting object graph to
type from the talk that I have in the
database I specified field by field and
if I ever want to make a sub query on
this I will just need to resolve that so
this is how I designed it for each talks
I will allow to get feedbacks and I need
to specify to the schema how it will
obtain those feedbacks so how easy you
specify the name as you did before and
then you tell it how to obtain the data
behind
okay so this is under the talks moving
along speaker easy so if I'm not
exposing here sub-query it won't be
available for me to use if I'm exposing
in this object type another sub query it
will be visible and under my main query
if I will comment feedbacks because now
I'm allowed to use feedbacks it won't
show up in the in the playground
okay so talks let's see what else is
available in here something that I
didn't show you before I give them names
like to be more intuitive but you can
use different different namings speaker
by ID
it's very so fish I mean you can use
this it will prompt you the ID you will
need to specific especi phi a number in
there and then you need to specify the
fields that you really want that so run
it and you'll get this for the speaker
with ID 2 and then we are gonna need
something else like description
description was there and twitter
perfectly fine it's not but this is not
resolved by me in in the fields okay
moving on if we're talking about
mutation is the same story so you need
to have a big class that will wrap
everything in my case called conference
mutation and you pretty much will expose
the available actions like create talk
and you also need to tell it how to
validate it will get what you pass is an
argument from the background and then
you will resolve that by saving it into
database
the same happens for example if I want
to create a new speaker I'm gonna
uncomment this
and I also will rely on something to
just speed up things mutation come on it
will open up so a mutation is not very
different but it has a keyword mutation
and it's playground and then I will have
pasted it in here so it's a mutation it
has a variable of speaker input type I
want back only these three fields
whenever I the operation succeeded and
then here I have a variable with the
properties I need and if I'm running
this you're gonna see that I get back
only the three fields that I specified
in the mutation back there and it also
it is in the database so if you want to
get back to the old times with so pitch
go ahead and use graph QL now I'm joking
graph QL is awesome just because even if
you are doing some extra stuff it
doesn't mean that you don't need to do
recipe ice for example the feedbacks
that I received its it were from a
different API called from server to
server so you need to make API that
aggregates data to expose them to
clients so client performance is first
[Music]
I'm getting there I'm getting there okay
so client performance first think about
it rest tends to get back to the the
client the fullest so what it has write
everything so a cool part of graph QL is
that it does exact setting you specify
what you need you get only that and
pretty much that's it it does less round
trips I mean it doesn't force you to
make three calls to get to populate the
page it
wonderful experience for humans once you
have the API ready and implemented and
if we think about it it has a cost
impact because you're transferring data
left to the network you in a way
reducing costs I mean everyone tries to
move to cloud getting data from cloud to
your client with I don't know properties
that they do not use means the cost and
reducing the amount of data you're
transferring means we're reducing the
cost also think about how much data
we're feeding through Facebook when
you're screwing into the app such kind
of experience wouldn't be possible
without practical I mean it if they
would been stuck with rest a lot of
calls were made and I think our life
wouldn't be so nice and the experience
of screwing Facebook over novelties
wouldn't be that nice so when it's cool
to switch over or try graph QL when you
have a REST API I mean only with the
main parts and when you want to defer
the understanding of the domain I mean
if you expose something to the API you
let the client the front-end guys decide
what they need you don't need to sync
with them anymore it's easy to get
started install that understand building
blocks it has that built-in
introspection that is a real cool it's
friendly and it's contract driven I mean
the client tells you I need that and
that and you just share it and now in
dotnet we have multiple duis that fish
to play around it's pretty awesome for
small project and when you need as a
business from the business perspective a
gateway like API I'm not telling you to
okay do not do recipes do them but if
the business requires it you can also
aggregate different api's into one an
exploit
expose graph QL endpoint when to you
that who are you care about bandwidth
and the cost associated with it and also
when you have no control over the client
app or if you have mobile app you expose
ApS for mobile or if you ever want to
empower your consumer is graphical
better than rest let's see this is
stolen from a dependency injection but
it works like a charm with a graph key L
the server doesn't drive the application
safe it's the other way around so the
client decides what are the next step
step that are made so problems you
pretty much forget about HTTP caching
and blah blah blah not possible I mean
how do you do caching you do not have a
plan to tell them through a header to
store the data in there you need to do
stuff in in memory
how about creating database you'll have
super performant queries right because
you're using graphical no you're not it
doesn't save you from getting data from
the database to your server side if you
need to I don't know improve performance
you need to do it and fine tune in your
queries yourself so it doesn't reach
through the database it's not skipping
layers it's there are the same principle
that applies there so you get data on
the server side you put graphic you own
it and you let the client decide from
your server side through the to it to
the client what data it wants not the
other way around you cannot say ok
here's the world kale parity here is it
to the database database give me only on
these fields and client here it is you
cannot do that so you're still bring
data over to the server side from the
database single endpoint and a single
post request means that your queries
they're not that understandable caching
it's not anymore
forget about that but pretty much they
are trying to improve this by using
something that is called data loader and
it tells an apparently work I didn't
show you it doesn't work trust me what
it does is basically creating some kind
of dictionary in code so bring data from
the database you're issuing a query to
the database and you keep it in memory
associated to a key and then next time
when the client issues the same request
it will serve that from in a memory in
the server to the client and this is how
they are trying to solve this caching
issue or you can do it yourself at the
read this layer and so on but it's still
working progress in this world yeah yeah
so this data loader tries to solve the
amplicon problem pretty much so bring
that data over and over again and also
it can batch multiple requests into one
so I have seven queries sent from the
client side you will need to modify your
repositories to accept IDs to bring more
data at once so it's not a silver bullet
in this in this area I already told you
you have to hold it in memory so
drawbacks where you can use it in pretty
much anything that can issue HTTP
requests can add the graph key on top of
it I think I'm running out of time
a few resources but there are a few guys
that are trying to improve this
graphical into dotnet open source and if
you ever want to contribute a lot of
people will thank you for that and what
I wanted to remain after this is that
although our distributed systems are
about trade-offs so I never ever throw
yourself into using a specific
technology without comparing several
technologies even if I don't know is
shrine and
pipe in the front and the world doesn't
mean that we should be forced to use it
of course it has a lot of benefits but
the drawbacks weren't there I mean not
having caching it's really worth it and
a single endpoint and not being able to
I don't know
for performance caching versus
performance versus less data transferred
from the server to the client you need
to balance that yourself so thank you
for being here today if there are any
questions I'll be around or DMA on on
Twitter I will gladly respond to those
so thank you
[Applause]